千万不要跟那种人性比较卑劣的男人有任何太深的交集，
因为人和人的命运是有可能相互转化的，
如果你跟一个人性特别卑劣的人发生很多的关系集，
发生很多的交集，
那么人的命运会发生转化。
越是这种人性很卑劣，
很凉薄，
很自私、
很没品、
很low的男人，
越要跟他尽早的划清界限。
我和这个男生认识几个月了，
家里的熟人长辈介绍认识的，
10月4号我们两个发生了关系，
就是发生关系的那天晚上，
我没有注意他没有做错事，
后面没有来生理期，
我昨天去医院发现我有宝宝了，
然后我就跟这个男生说怎么处理，
因为我们感情不是特别好，
就是我们俩肯定是不会在一起的，
我已经打定主意了，
这个嘛，
昨天晚上我跟他谈，
我就说了，
这个宝宝不能要我嘛，
我把那个去医院做那个B超啊检查，
我拿给他看，
因为宝宝太小了，
才20多天，
上面没有那个子卵黄囊，
我下个星期还要再去做一次，
然后他看那个报告，
他说这个上面怎么没有孩子的那个周期月份呢？
我不确定这个孩子到底是不是我的，
他一开口就说这个，
我当时我有点懵住了，
我们就在这个怎么解决，
他说这个孩子如果确定是我的，
你不。
放心，
我可以陪你去医院，
但是我只出这个手术费，
而且实他的任何费用他都不承担，
而且他还要在现场盯着，
我的内心其实非常的愤怒，
昨天晚上的话，
我给他发了消息，
我说下个星期你陪我再去医院做B超，
你跟医生你问清楚，
你看看这个孩子到底是谁的，
他给他发消息，
他就再也没有回了，
我们俩是知根知底的，
我知道他家重要，
他的工作什么的，
我想问一下我怎么维护我的权益，
姑娘，
我说实话啊，
对于你来说，
最有利的一个选项是拉黑他这件事情，
如果你有特别信得过的姐姐、
朋友，
或者说自己的妈妈什么的，
让他们陪你去做这个手术，
不要跟这个人有任何的纠葛，
有任何的纠纷，
有任何的这种情感上的拉扯，
为什么呢？
因为对于我们女孩子来说，
可能以后你的相亲啊，
谈对象啊，
这些东西更重要一点，
某种程度上在现有的阶段就看清楚这个男人的嘴脸，
对于你来说的话，
也是一件很庆幸的事情，
在这个孩子就二十几天三十几天的时候去做这个手术的话，
其实花不了多少钱，
可能也就是一天两天的就解决掉了，
没有必要为了这个钱去跟他再有更深的感情的纠葛，
就确实。
是一个非常不上道儿的，
或者说非常下作的一个男人，
他越是这么下作的男人的话，
我们作为女人，
我经常跟大家讲一个道理，
就是你不能跟屎去打架，
你作为巧克力，
你要跟屎打一架的话，
就算你打赢了，
你浑身沾满了屎，
理解这个逻辑了，
您说的这个办法我之前也想过，
我问了我身边的朋友，
这个钱我可以出，
因为这个钱确实也没多少，
但是我心里这口气很难受，
我跟你讲，
姑娘，
首先我们要承担自己的责任，
在对一个男人没有深入的了解，
不了解他的人品的时候，
就贸然跟他上床是我的错，
在上床的时候没有在没有做保护措施，
这是我的错，
在结束了之后，
我没有去买那个紧急避孕药，
我自己吃，
这也是我的错，
所以我今天要做的这件事情是为我自己的这三个错误去买单，
无论是花1000也好，
花2000也好，
这是我为我自己的人生和错误在买单，
这样的话，
你的心态就会平和一点，
你成长的速度会更快一点，
千万不要跟那种人性比较卑劣的男人有任何太深的交集，
因为人和人的命运是有可能相互转化的，
如果你跟一个人性特别卑劣的人发生很多的关系，
发生很多的交集，
那么人的命运会发生转化。
越是这。
人性很卑劣，
很凉薄，
很自私，
很没挺，
很low的男人，
越要跟他尽早的划清界限，
因为我心里是有两个声音的，
一个声音就是这个钱我不在乎，
但是我要让他付出一点代价，
不管是精神上的还是什么样的，
然后另一个声音就是远离这些烂人烂事，
我拿不准主意，
我才想问你，
然后就是您刚刚这样说了就知道了，
然后我内心也会说清楚，
至少告诉你自己，
因为我其实这个事情发生以后，
我想过了，
就是我自己也有责任，
我承认，
就是我提前看清楚这个人是什么样的，
我没跟他结婚嘛，
那要是结婚以后发生这种事情那更糟糕，
这些东西我全部都想了一遍，
我只是现在有一点乱，
我想听一下您的建议，
如果听我的建议的话，
就是拉黑他，
不要让他参与任何你接下来要去动手术也好，
干嘛的所有的事情不要让他参与任何的东西，
就是报复，
这个心我是能理解你的报复一定是什么，
一定是当我是权力的上位者，
我再实施这样的行为，
一定是当我如果有一天强大到我可以影响到他的赚钱的能力的时候，
我再去实施这个行为。
但如果说我报复一个男人会让我两败俱伤，
会让我名声受损，
会让我在以后的毕亲和陈家这件事情上有阻碍的话，
那我认为如果现在我去报复他的话，
是我自己蠢，
如果有一天我是他的老板，
如果有一天我是他。
的领导，
如果有一天我可以决定他的经济命脉，
如果有一天我可以决定他的工作得失，
那我也可以君子报仇，
十年不晚好的，
因为就是我问了我身边的人，
他们都是只要让这个男生付出代价，
我之前我想过要不要就我自己承受了，
就当我吃了一颗屎了。
两个观点一直在我脑子里面，
我觉得现阶段对于你来说最划算的方式就是越少的人知道这件事情，
越少的人牵扯越少的这种情感纠葛越划算。
好，
我知道了，
就这样啊，
嗯，
谢谢你，
拜拜，
报复心可强了，
但我的复一定要建立在我绝对安全的基础之上，
谁能懂我这个点？
就是我的报复一定是建立在我绝对安全的基础之上，
就是我整理的时候，
你未必知道是我在整你，
但是我是绝对安全，
所有的女孩子啊，
不要怕人家觉得你记仇，
不要怕人家觉得你记较，
因为只有他们都知道你记仇，
都知道你计较，
他才会忌惮，
他才不敢肆无忌惮的伤害你，
欺负你。
记得点赞关注哦。